- My comic book skills are like...
- Zero.
- My four-year-old son draws
better comic books than I do.
(upbeat music)
My dream superhero is very sensitive,
kind guy whose gift is posing
in bodybuilding contests and also
helping people understand the world over.
We call him Mr. Understanding.
- Does he have a weakness?
- His weakness is he's just too kind.
Sometimes he just feels too much.
You know what I mean?
He just--
- That's great, is he bald?
Does he have hair?
- He has to be bald because he has to
understand the feelings of the people
who have no hair.
He has to be able to identify with them.
- Mine's gonna, you know,
it's gonna be a dude.
I like female superheroes, but I like
to be in love with my superheroes
and I like dudes.
He is holding a baby 'cause he's a dad
and he's carrying a diaper bag.
And also, wait a second, wait,
and then back here is,
he also cleans the house
so here's a bucket.
Husbandman.
- OK, does he have a secret weapon?
- His secret weapon, he can--
- He can balance a child while
doing all the chores.
- Yeah, while also doing chores.
This sounds great, I love this.
- Do you have an idea of what
their superpower is yet?
- Yes.
- What is it?
- All the cool ones in one guy.
- I see it's looking a little familiar.
- Yep.
- Drawing some inspiration.
- Uh huh.
- Superman.
Who woulda thought?
Why is that the dream superhero?
- Superman is the best of us in the sense
that he has gone through all the trials
and tribulations of slings and arrows
of growth, of being hated,
of not being wanted, of wanting to do
everything for humanity and not being
able to achieve it, being disappointed
in himself and still coming back
fighting every time.
- It's so ugly, I don't know even...
I can do better, I'm afraid to show.
- [Host] Let's see it.
- You sure?
- Yeah, I'm sure it's great.
Oh, she's adorable, yeah.
- She's adorable, yeah.
- What's her name?
- She's kind, she's
goodhearted, she's happy,
she's positive, she inspires people.
- Posi Girl maybe?
- Posi Girl?
- Like Positive Girl?
- OK, Posi Girl.
- He was born in the Silicon Valley.
He was meant to help us, make us better,
but he's in a lot of
ways stolen our lives.
- What's their personality like?
- He adopts our personality.
- I feel like you've
thought about this before.
I'm into it.
(laughs) There we go, I should have known.
- iPhoneman!
iPhoneman would be played by Zac Efron.
(laughter)
- Zac's got the legs for it.